Disability activists in South Korea are being sued by the subway authority...
…for causing major disruption in Seoul in the morning rush hour.
Solidarity Against Disability Discrimination say they want all stations...
...to be wheelchair accessible.
And more funding allocated to disability provisions in the national budget.
But the authority's hardline response has led to a bitter feud and clashes...
…between demonstrators and security forces.
Nick Marsh's report from the capital contains scenes...
…that some viewers may find distressing.
In Seoul, there's a battle happening at rush hour.
Underground, disabled South Koreans want equal access to their city subway system.
Blocking train doors and shaving their heads in protest.
Seoul's mayor has vowed zero tolerance, but it hasn't stopped the demonstrations.
I've been hit by commuters.
I've been followed home.
People shout at us.
They say, "why don't you stay at home?"
But the gap between disabled and non disabled people here is so huge,...
…that we have to continue.
Among commuters though, sympathy is in short supply.
I was one hour late from a hospital appointment because of this.
Why would it have to cause harm to innocent citizens?
Look at all this.
How many facilities the disabled already have?
I agree with the police.
The people here say they want to be able to get around their own city,...
…just like everybody else.
But the way they've gone about it hasn't exactly won them...
…many friends from commuters.
Then again, neither has the response from the authorities.
It's been pretty quiet here this morning and yet the people here...
…have been outnumbered by police and riot police by about five to one.
It's not a great look.